to bleed I love bleeding I love bleeding
so much that you know what I hate I hate
the three days before my period that's
when I feel the absolute worst the
heaviest the headaches everything but
once the cork pops yeah and once I see
that first sight of blood I'm like thank
God then the weight sort of sheds the
the period pains go away yeah I've
always honestly as a man cuz I've lived
as a man for a very long time I believe
you believe I mean I sure I think you
know I think I know yeah but you know I
all I know is this wouldn't it be just
for a year I would want to know what
it's like to be a woman but actually
just biologically a woman go through the
menstrual cycle I LA and other women
what they go through right maybe I'm
just getting really moody too you know
man oh yeah yes you know maybe like
really [ __ ] up about things yeah you
know how women do it I don't get exactly
quiet
whatever I don't know but you know III
don't get [ __ ] I get teary-eyed I get
emotional also cry over nothing when you
do I also I would like to know like what
it'd be like to be a hot woman to go to
a bar see I just would like to that
experience of like how creepy dudes get
right some dude is eyeing you and then
me just you know I mean I am them back
like what have you seen the show altered
carbon uh Netflix know so that's what
that show is really you can purchase new
bodies and they called sleeves so you
can buy a woman's body or like see a
child dies so these parents can't afford
a new body for the child like a kid's
body because they're expensive they'll
put their child's like mine like in a
fifty year old person that's only what's
available so it's very sci-fi it's
pretty good it's what what channel is
enough hang on but does the fifty year
old body then act like
a child yeah it's sad you see the
parents like their kid gets in a car
accident but they save the memories they
put in a new body it's all they can
afford say it's a seven-year-old man
they see the man you just see this man
crying saying mom and it's just an old
man though oh cool I wanna watch I want
to change his attitude not his body so
can i buy mean take like LeBron James
memories have put into Bobby's body put
somebody can you deal with the flavors
gonna put a different person in your
body yeah she doesn't want to be with me
but could you put a dog like your dog
died can you put it in an old man's body
I didn't see any go hey go being that
you know I mean the old man I didn't see
it in this show but someone did insult
some of you ever [ __ ] talk back to me
I'll put your [ __ ] body in a dog
sleeve so it could have oh and vice
versa maybe yeah what an interesting
concept
yeah did you guys know that Ricky
Gervais was a pop star in the
Philippines in the 80s